c'est entendu casimir tu peux compter
sur moi c'est très gentil d'avoir pensé
à moi
encore merci julie alors arrête tout à
l'heure à total un bon jour julie tu as
une minute à me consacrer même de ses
cheveux de quoi s'agit-il
je viens de recevoir une invitation du
facteur écoute bien mon cher françois
j'organise aujourd'hui un chocolat dans
son bureau de poste pour célébrer mes
dix ans d'ancienneté
je compte sur vous venez avec une
cavalière du conte propos que je suis là
tu veux me demander d'y aller avec trois
exactement julie et d'amphibiens
j'accepte ça m'aurait fait très plaisir
prend soin mais je suis déjà retenu
quelqu'un d'autre mad fait la même
proposition et bien tant pis je lis on
va de toute façon se verra là bas à tout
à l'heure je suis désolé un françois
ferrieux ça fait rien monsieur du snob a
dû l'inviter avant moi qui d'autre
pourrait inviter comme c'est gentil de
ta part mon petit lapin rose ans quand
on est un grand mot damier de mes chutes
et te dis oui trois fois oui oui oui
bon eh bien alors à tout à l'heure je
vous répète pour la 15e fois comme je ne
suis pas un lapin au sucre ma chère mme
loiselle chuté permettez moi de vous
saluer bien bas en beaux jours dix neuf
mais appelez moi futé en toute impunité
je suis désolé ma chère amie et mon
éducation ne me le permet pas volonté
jamais oublier
que voulez-vous injuste tout d'abord
permettez moi de vous offrir cette
feuille rarissime qu'un de mes amis
explorateurs réputé m'a envoyé à m mais
non seulement je n'ai déjà mais elle est
tout mythe et enfin merci quand même
c'est toujours que nous pas tout à fait
voilà je voulais vous inviter au
chocolat dansant des facteurs est
possible pourquoi vous vous ne savez pas
danser et même très bien
enfin sauf avec ceux qui mettent l'envié
souligna non mais je suis désolé j'ai
déjà un cavalier gendre est alors dans
ce cas je ne s'y est pas jusqu 'au
revoir' mademoiselle chuté au world is
now bonjour bonjour françois francoual a
déjà évité je crois qu'il avait déjà
invité julie tant mieux je vais y aller
[Musique]
bonjour et donner un max en ballons ses
rangs de la malle il le faut oui mais ça
ne va pas mon garçon six enfants et mais
je suis venu pour vous inviter au
chocolat dansant du facteur que non mais
vous étiez les gens courent pourquoi ne
serais-je pas m'excuser mots mais je
viens tout juste de recevoir cette
invitation à vous accepter
hélas je dois vous dire trois fois non
non non et non je suis déjà évité et
bien tant pis ce sera pour une autre
fois en voit parfois bien cette fois
c'est le facteur qui a été plus vite que
moi notre demande me touche beaucoup
aussi dix neuf c'est normal ma chère
amie j'ai tout de suite pensé à vous
pour être ma cavalière vous savez quel
admiration je vous porte mais il aurait
fallu aller encore plus vite
ap routes dites moi pourquoi vous
angoisse et bien je suis obligé de vous
dire non quelqu'un d'autre m'a proposé
d'être sa cavalière et jacques
c'est pts et le fact haut
je suis désespéré moi qui me faisais une
joie de danser avec vous à cette petite
fête chez nous ils en seront quand même
monsieur disnat oui évidemment mais
j'aurais voulu arriver avec vous au
bureau de poste à mon bras vous est sans
nul doute la personne la plus élégante
de l'île aux enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi si je suis bon n'est ce pas des
chats il faut que je me donne un coup de
brosse
oh là là mais il faut que je vérifie
match alors mon beau casimir tu vas au
chocolat dans ce temps du facteur ouais
et alors tu sais qu'il te faut une
cavalière
alors là ne vous en faites pas pour moi
j'en ai même deux 2 mais qui est bien
julie et mademoiselle fut tué que ça
chez la personne pour nous maintenant
mais si mais si il y à mademoiselle
cunégonde la standardiste de la poste et
cunégonde c'est tout à fait charmant
ruelle que son éducation ne laisse rien
à désirer totalement impossible mais
pourquoi
et parce qu'elle écrase sans arrêt les
pieds de ses danseurs oui c'est avec
elle que j'ai perdu ma dernière paire de
chaussures en les argents d'australie
mans j'en suis sincèrement désolé pour
vous monsieur l'histoire mais voici
casimir
voilà ton ennemi pour est mythique
navire
comment tu as invité aussi maniable futé
oui mais mais avec toi quoi mais je ne
suis pas ta seule cavalière
ah non j'ai également invité julie mais
casimir ça ne se fait pas monsieur du
snav accepteriez vous d'être mon
cavalier mettrait volontiers prenais mon
bras françois vécu que nous allions
ensemble
rien ne peut me faire plus plaisir joli
mais moi alors je vais rester tout seul
mais non viens avec nous il te reste
mademoiselle cunego non vous avez dit
qu'elle marchait sur les pieds deux
pouces et danseurs
oui mais toi tu ne risques rien avec le
ventre que tu vas elle n'arrivera jamais
jusqu'à tes pieds
[Musique]